Wow I mean they're in a tough spot
because thats you know i wouldn't want
to be a Republican candidate right now
because you know the president is so
unpopular he's so damaged the brand of
his party so has the Republican Congress
and none of these guys for very
practical political reasons have been
willing or able to really firmly break
the president so I would say that I
candidate depends who the candidate is
how easy this is but my completely
armchair uninformed point of view would
be that for Republican candidate to win
in 2008 they're going to have to break
strongly with the with the legacy of
this administration and the legacy
congressional Republicans and articulate
a new way forward that separates them
from from the recent past